ich bin neulich in der Papierfabrik
gegangen und dort kam der dort kam der
Chef auf mich zu und sagte sie kommen an
dem Tag wo zum ersten Mal die
Personalkosten geringer sind als sie
Energie kosten und das ist sozusagen die
der Abgrund von dem wir stehen den sie
eben auch angesprochen haben und die
Frage ist wie gehen wir jetzt damit um
und jetzt kann man der Meinung sein und
das würde ich unterstützen dass das eine
Form auch von kreativer Zerstörung sein
kann
der Krieg in der Ukraine die hohen
Energiepreise können ein Booster sein
für Innovationen und darauf setze ich
eigentlich dieser Booster der muss zwei
verschiedene Wege gehen das eine ist er
muss innovative Wege aufzeigen um
Energie zu sparen und da sind die Firmen
dran sie haben eben BASF erwähnt BASF
zum Beispiel sitzt an einer gigantischen
Wärmepumpe Pumpe das wird die größte der
Welt die die bauen zusammen mit man und
die versuchen dann die die Prozesswärme
dort selbst zu erzeugen das ist das eine
also Energiesparen und das andere ist
Innovationen in Form von neuartigen
wegen Energie zu erzeugen wie kann ich
was gibt es denn eigentlich was ist noch
in der Fusionstechnik drin was steckt
noch in der Kernkraft drin können wir
vielleicht Fracking tatsächlich
umweltschonend bei uns hinkriegen diese
Innovation zu fördern ich glaube darin
liegt eine große Chance
es bleibt uns nichts anderes übrig
glaube ich aber mir fehlt halt also wie
sagen ich bin ja absolut bei Ihnen dass
dass man jetzt neu denken muss also dass
man dass man einfach Dinge auch jetzt
mal durchdenken muss an die man sich
jetzt jahrelang geleistet hat nicht
nachzudenken müssen wir uns dann auch
ein bisschen als von der Exportnation
Bundesrepublik verabschieden müssen wir
eine ganz neue ganz neu denken
das glaube ich nicht weil weil ich sie
können ein ganzes Land nicht einfach
umkrempeln aber Krisen sind ja eben
insofern das Positive an Krisen ist dass
sie Ausnahmen von der Regel zulassen
oder auch erfordern ja das heißt viele
Dinge die vorher nicht möglich waren zu
diskutieren muss man dann in der Krise
diskutieren weil einem nichts anderes
übrig bleibt und deswegen sind Krisen
eigentlich immer eine große Chance eben
auch für Innovation aber eben auch die
Chance sozusagen festgefahrenes
Gedankengut auch vielleicht über Bord zu
werfen und zu sagen wir müssen jetzt neu
denken weil das was wir uns ausgedacht
haben hat nicht funktioniert und
deswegen auch die ich bin würde ich
sagen kaum jemand in diesem Land ist ja
gegen den weiteren Ausbau irgendwie von
erneuerbaren Energien aber damit können
sie halt in ein Industrieland einfach
nicht führen das heißt wir brauchen ganz
andere industriemengen als wir
herstellen können jetzt nur durch
erneuerbare und schon gar nicht
kurzfristig und wenn man sowieso darüber
also wenn man sowieso die Alternative
ist dass man zum Beispiel sagen wir mal
schmutziges Gas von woanders kauft warum
sozusagen nicht das eigene Gas nehmen
also es ist nahezu paradox welche
gedankenbarrieren wir haben einfach aus
ideologischen Gründen und deswegen finde
ich es gut wenn man dieser Krise ja
sagen wir mal experimenteller wäre ja
klar
tatsächlich war Deutschland immer ein
Vorbild auch für die Türkei wie wird es
heute gesehen nimmt man uns eigentlich
noch ernst nein also das kann man ganz
offen sagen also in der Türkei wird über
Deutschland das ist nur kopfschütten ich
hatte vor zwei Monaten war ich schon
wieder bei dem Präsidium der dhp also
der türkischen haben wir auch mal
diskutiert ich sagen also wie können die
so eine Politik machen also ich bin ja
hier aufgewachsen ich habe diesem Land
sehr viel zu verdanken ich liebe dieses
Land auch und deswegen kritisiere ich
das auch auch als Beamter ich weiß dass
dass man sich damit ja auch nicht sehr
beliebt macht aber darum geht's mir
nicht mit Liebesentzug kann ich leben
aber ich kann nicht damit leben wenn man
kreative Zerstörung finde ich gut aber
das was wir machen ist eine unkreative
Zerstörung der Industrie und eine
bewusste Zerstörung unserer Industrie ne
weil Sparsamkeit also kein Land ist doch
sparsam wie Deutschland ja also ich habe
meine meine in meinem Studentenzeit hat
man hat man schon über Contracting und
über Energie und Sparsamkeit das war
doch immer deutsches sozusagen Gebot ja
und jetzt sozusagen den Leuten jetzt so
zu suggerieren man könnte mit bisschen
sparen und ein paar Waschlappen jetzt
würde ich sagen Energie kriegen also das
ist wirklich bei Seiten beobachten also
ich finde ihre ihren Ausspruch in der
Türkei lacht man übrigens das finde ich
prima das ist so kann man sich hier auch
mal wirklich gut merken aber ich glaube
das gilt wenn man sich die politische
Entscheidungswege hier anbelangt also
ein großer Energieverbraucher zu sein
eine große Industrie zu haben aber
sämtliche
Energieträger abzuschalten oder Atom und
Kohle gleichzeitig also das ist
sicherlich etwas was in der Türkei auf
Unverständnis stößt ja aber auf der
anderen Seite und das ist ja das was ich
meinte auf der anderen Seite haben wir
nach wie vor eine hoch kreative
Industrie und die denken sich was aus
und ich bin einfach ja ich bin am Ende
fortschrittsgläubig ich glaube dass wir
in einer was neues erfährst du sagen sie
unkreativ im Gegensatz zu kreativ weil
die die sozusagen die Industrialisierung
digitaler Wandel Klimawandel das benutzt
man in Deutschland so gleichzeitig das
sind völlig unterschiedliche Wege also
bei der die beim digitalen Wandel da
geht's wirklich so sagen um abskilling
und downskilling weil viele glauben na
ja wenn man sozusagen bisschen
Innovation dann hat man immer nur ein
Roboter dann braucht man nur sozusagen
Techniker Ingenieure nein auch dann
braucht man gerade
Variante Arbeiter die wirklich sozusagen
von Robotern gesteuert werden so und
wenn man sozusagen das heißt also immer
wieder energieintensiv und diese diese
diese Ideen sozusagen auch mit mit
Nuklearenergie wo kommt denn der uranium
her dass ich mal die Amerikaner
Amerikaner
müssen jetzt waffenfähiges uranium
nehmen weil sie an Russland sozusagen
also Russland ist nicht ohne Grund und
Schachspieler ja wir spielen vielleicht
mensch ärger dich nicht gut aber das
sind die Leute strategische und ich
glaube nicht dass der Putin ein Maniac
ist also er ist kaltherzig er ist brutal
aber ist rational auf das Thema da gehen
wir um mit Russland deswegen also
Innovationsstandort Deutschland ja wenn
Sie das Thema Uran ansprechen es stimmt
ganz viel Uran kommt aus Russland aber
unterm Strich sind 20%. das heißt 80%
kommen woanders her dann kommt noch ein
bisschen was aus Kasachstan aber 60%
kommen mal aus ganz anderen Ecken das
heißt ich glaube dass man mit diesem mit
diesem Material auch aus
unverdächtigeren Quellen genug beziehen
kann um eine entsprechende Forschung
erfahren zu treiben das ist sicherlich
ist sicherlich ein Weg und noch mal die
Innovation die die Industrie schafft die
hat uns die letzten 200 Jahre begleitet
und warum soll das jetzt mit einmal
aufhören gibt's also ich bin überzeugt
klar ich bin selber innovationsfan und
ich mag Schumpeter mit für seine aber
die Innovation erfordert Monopol Gewinne
so diese Gewinne müssen sie erstmal
erwirtschaften und bei diesen
Energiepreisen können Sie von froh sein
wenn sie sozusagen nicht pleite gehen
und da haben sie überhaupt auch keine
Innovation sozusagen Möglichkeiten oder
genug Profite um ihn Innovation zu
stecken das ist ja sozusagen da fängt
das Thema an und ich sage ja wir sind
wir haben super Ingenieure wir haben
super Produkte aber diese Produkte die
gehen nur dann wenn wir sozusagen auf
die nie günstigen import-stoffe
sozusagen Rohstoffe und Energie das ist
ja nicht nur Gas es ist nicht nur
sondern Platinum oder auch sozusagen
jetzt Palladium oder von mir aus Nickel
oder Xenon was man sozusagen für die
also vieles kommt ja also Russland ist
quasi wie so ein Supermarkt für die
Industrie und da muss man dann halt mal
dran denken
ist voll auch mit diesen Stoffen von
woanders oder und Sie müssen sie können
sie wollen also in die Innovation
sozusagen von von einem von einem
russischen
sie behaupten jetzt dass wir Russland
bräuchten um innovativ zu sein und das
ist ja doch aber sie behaupten eine
Abhängigkeit über die wir eben auch noch
nicht innovativ nachgedacht haben wie
wir diese Abhängigkeit abbauen können
das wäre zum Beispiel auch eine Form von
Innovation dass man sagt das kann doch
nicht sein dass wir abhängig sind quasi
von Russland und jemanden wie Putin
erdulden müssen mit all dem was
erfordert und mit der Kaltherzigkeit und
mit allem was Sie gerade ja auch selber
geschildert haben nur um selber noch
irgendwie unsere Energie unsere
Innovation oder sonst was abzudecken
sondern Innovation und Kreativität würde
bedeuten wie kommen wir aus einer
Situation heraus wo wir abhängig sind
von jemandem den wir gefallen müssen
also dieses Thema Abhängigkeit finde ich
ja sehr schön und auch sehr goldig aber
letztlich mit wenn man mit einem
Vertragspartner zusammen ist und er ist
günstig er ist zuverlässig das ist
diesmal Russland dann ist das Katar oder
China und wenn ich uranium nehme bei dem
Beispiel ich glaube die beide Länder
China und Russland haben über 60 Prozent
da können Sie jetzt einen sozusagen eine
Art
autoritäre Regime mit einem anderen
sozusagen ersetzen aber sie kommen immer
in einer Abhängigkeit also der Preise
sehen irgendwie egal wenn ich das also
sage okay es ist eigentlich egal ob
Diktatoren sind oder ob das andere man
muss Handeltreiben und damit der
Wirtschaftsstandort Deutschland
überlegen will nein ich sage das nicht
sagt nein ich sage es sind immer
irgendwelche sozusagen also ich meine
ist Katar jetzt ein besseres Land mit
dem wir jetzt irgendwie Geschäfte im
Moment ja also gerade kein Angriffskrieg
gegen sein Nachbarland also ich bin zwar
auch kein großer Freund von Katar aber
Russland führt gerade diesen Krieg und
dann müssen wir jetzt leider wechseln
und ich würde am liebsten auch nicht
nach Katar unsere die Energie dort von
dort besorgen aber ich weiß nicht wir
haben im Moment gar keine andere Wahl
und das ist doch der einzige Hebel wenn
wir diesen Krieg nicht eingreifen wollen
dass wir Russland wenigstens
ökonomischer Schaden und ja ich sehe da
keine Alternativ ich finde die Idee klar
dass man in der Not wird man
erfinderisch ja aber die
erfinderlichkeit sozusagen die
erfindungserzählung das unterstütze ich
auch aber die muss natürlich auch
finanziert werden und wenn wir sozusagen
der Industrie jetzt schon sozusagen das
Genick brechen dann ist es mit
Innovation vorbei ist wir brechen ja
nicht das Genick selbst die die stark
betroffenen Firmen sie haben BASF
genannt Bayern die großen Chemiefirmen
die Bayer hat vor vier Jahren Monsanto
für 60 Milliarden Dollar gekauft das
heißt da liegen unglaublich viele
Reserven die ist den möglich machen
jetzt in dieser Krise zu überleben das
sind ja auch nicht Firmen die nur in
Deutschland produzieren oder nur in
Deutschland verkaufen sondern die sind
weltweit aufgestellt und wenn es da
nicht läuft woanders ein bisschen
das andere Thema was eben Ansprachen ich
glaube wir brauchen auf Dauer einen
freien Handel wir brauchen auf Dauer
einen freien Handel mit China wir
brauchen einen ausgerechnet auch mit
China wir haben gerade das Thema mit dem
Hamburger Hafen und ich finde es
bemerkenswert wie der Kanzler als
ehemaliger Oberbürgermeister von Hamburg
sich als Held des Freihandels mit einmal
auch ich finde das gut die glaube ich
nicht so oder ich finde man muss
vorsichtig sein also gerade auch die
sagen wir mal die Erfahrung mit Russland
hat uns ja jetzt gerade auch gezeigt
wohin das führen kann wenn man sag mal
unberechenbaren Ländern weil würde ich
ihn nämlich auch sie sagten gerade
Russland sei zuverlässig mit Verlauf
nein Russland da weiß ich gerade als
nicht zuverlässiger Partner
unter diesem Aspekt finde ich es muss
man schon vorsichtig sein und fand ich
es sehr sehr erstaunlich mit welcher
Leichtigkeit Olaf Scholz sozusagen den
Chinesen auch durchaus einen Anteil
gegeben hätte wo sie in der
schwerminorität gehabt und jetzt hat man
es runter gehandelt aber die Chinesen
kaufen sich weltweit in die in die Häfen
ein und nicht überall
tut das den Ländern dort gut und die
Chinesen tun das mit einer großen
Strategie und das darf man jetzt nicht
vergessen also wir sollten lernen
eigentlich aus dieser Erfahrung mit
Russland dass man eben nicht zu viel
Macht geben darf gerade im
Energiebereich oder auch in der Logistik
einem fremden Land dass man nicht
berechnen kann ganz kurze Frage halten
Sie das für Doppelmoral
dass wir jetzt unseren Russland
unabhängig machen wollen und dafür in
andere Länder dafür sozusagen in unserer
helfen reinlassen ja auf jeden Fall und
am liebsten wäre mir tatsächlich eine
Wirtschaft die komplett unabhängig von
jeglichen diktatorischen Regimen ist
aber
wir haben nun mal diese Abhängigkeiten
im Moment und ja wir würden wir am
liebsten würden wir natürlich unabhängig
werden aber im Moment ist natürlich der
Fokus auf Russland dass wir von Russland
unabhängig werden und da natürlich Frau
bärbock sagt Werte geleitete
Außenpolitik noch wir stecken mit allen
Fingern mit allen Ländern in irgendwie
in Verbindung und deshalb ist das von
heute auf morgen nicht möglich obwohl es
natürlich wünschenswert wäre und deshalb
ist mir wichtig dass man halt eben auf
Russland jetzt sich konzentriert und
schaut weil Russland für diesen Krieg
dass wir von dort unsere Assets abziehen
und uns von Russland wenigstens
unabhängig machen auch für die Zukunft
und nicht nur jetzt in Zeiten dieses
Krieges